on the ground and kanun in the southern
part of the Gaza Strip thank you so much
yumna please stay
safe well we can now bring in guy shalev
he is the executive director of
Physicians for human rights Israel he
joins us now from Tel Aviv doctor I
understand you're very much still in
close contact with doctors on the ground
right now in Gaza what have they been
telling
you right so first of all this is uh uh
the interaction that we have with local
doctors in Gaza for the past 35 years
especially in the past 16 17 years since
the blockade on Gaza started and we are
maintaining our close ties with our
colleagues in Gaza we talking uh to
Marana and
to who you've also been talking to in Al
jazer and we're getting reports uh from
what's happening on the ground about the
Israeli attack of medical facilities uh
that has become uh impossible in the
past two days I would say and definitely
now right now when elifa hospital is
under direct attack you're suggesting
there that things have escalated in the
last couple of days we've certainly seen
that let me ask you about your
understanding of the intentionality here
both of the strikes that we've seen as
well as The Siege doctors on the ground
have also been telling us that they
believe that Israel intends to cause
death by
deprivation right so when we're talking
about direct attack of the medical
facilities in Gaza it hasn't started
yesterday or today
the decision not to let any clean water
food fuel for the hospital generators in
is already an attack on the Gaza health
system and it already is causing a lot
of pain and destruction and death even
before we got to this point now where
the military the Israel military is
encircling a shifa hospital which is
definitely uh becoming ever more urgent
to protect these medical facilities um I
I I don't think I think it's our role to
decide on intentionality that the the
facts on the ground are clear patients
and medical staff are being targeted
they they they are uh being uh put in
Risk they they do not have the equipment
they need the medications they need and
we are hearing about chronic disease uh
patients as well as injured uh patients
that cannot get the medical treatment
that they require in order to survive
well Israel has been say saying that
they're targeting Hamas right in your
experience and that of the many many
doctors that you work with are there any
Hamas operations in or under hospitals
in the Gaza
Strip right we don't have any
information direct information on that
we know that Israel is claiming that for
for since 2009 and have yet seen any
validated evidence by a third party to
that fact or that argument or that claim
we know that we go to aifa every month
with our delegation with doctors going
there walking around the corridors uh
providing Health Care doing surgeries
and they they report they've never seen
Hamas militants walking around a shifa
hospital and it must be clear that even
if these claims by the military are true
which still we don't have any evidence
to that it doesn't allow any uh in any
under any international law to Target
the patients and the medical staff in
there and still there's any possibility
of safe evacuation which we currently
cannot see especially now when the
hospital is in circle yeah and when I'm
talking about safe evacuation I'm
talking about ambulances medical stuff I
mean if you need to move around a baby
in an incubator you need the the uh the
conditions to do that safely and also
you need someplace safe to evacuate you
uh the Gaza Ministry of Health have been
requesting since this uh War has has
started to have patients especially
chronic disease patients evacuated out
of the Gaza Street and were not allowed
to do so I know that turkey offered to
to provide health healthare for them
Egypt provide offered to provide
healthare for them but still they are
stranded in these hospitals so as long
as they are there they cannot become a
legitimate Target to any military action
let me take a step back and ask you this
you're sitting right now in Tel Aviv and
you're the executive director of
Physicians for human rights in Israel
how are doctors in Israel feeling right
now as they watch what's happening in
the Gaza Strip and and do you feel that
you're being heard in
Israel yes this is a very difficult
times to to speak out in Israel we know
of our colleagues and friends are being
arrested just for showing any empathy
with Gaza so the public debate in Israel
is very problematic and a lot of the
doctors that we are working with are
just afraid to speak up out especially
our Palestinian doctors Palestinian
citizens of Israel who are really at
risk of being attacked by the government
for anything they say even if they post
something on social media so this is the
atmosphere that we are working in uh we
know a few days ago as you reported
there was a letter by Israeli doctors
who urged the Israeli government to
attack Gaz and hospitals we saw that as
a
uh impossible violation of medical
ethics these doctors has resorted to we
issued our own statement signed by more
than 300 medical personnel uh arguing
that in not in any uh uh condition a
hospital can become a Target um we are
calling from here from Tel Aviv to our
government to governments all over the
world this needs to stop now not
tomorrow not I don't know in two hours
from now all the pressure needs to put
on the Israeli government to stop this
attack on hospitals and medical
facilities it it it can't be a minute
too early to do so K shal there the
executive director of Physicians for
human rights Israel joining us from Tel
Aviv thank you so much for sharing your
thoughts here with us on Al jaaz
doctor thank
you well speaking at a joint Summit of
the Arab League and the organization of
Islamic cooperation the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia Muhammad bin Salman called
for an immediate end to the
hostilities as we reiterate our
condemnation of This ferocious brutal
War under which our Palestinian brothers
are railing as a result of which
thousands of civilians were killed
hospitals places of workship worship
were destroyed the kingdom has been
exerting uh concerted efforts continue
to consult and coordinate with brother
and friendly states to